[Music]
in kidnapping nanny news Oh the nanny
got kidnapped or the nanny kidnapped I'm
pretty sure the nanny kidnaps submitted
by pineapple pizza I love pineapple
pizza that ham I owe him just food one
slice that's all I'm gonna take a woman
confessed to her son that she actually
kidnapped him from his real parents 26
years I would [ __ ] him pop my mom and a
job [ __ ] yeah you just bring that up and
why did you out of nowhere I would just
keep it a secret just to let you know
you're not mine what's that movie
doesn't the kidnapper but basically the
same thing surprise I'm your mom it's
like if I grew up in a black family and
I'm like no what do you mean did you
guys ever wish you were adopted no like
a photography like trick yeah where it
looked like they doubled me yeah so it
looked like I had a twin for the longest
time when I was little
oh you wanted a twin could you have
siblings can you give her a hug no I
wouldn't have meant to say I wanted a
twin oh we have siblings I do any her
siblings but because of that photos
[ __ ] me up and I could have swore my
parents like hid the fact that I had a
sister somewhere okay that one right
that's what Mary Cain actually when I
was little so I would like all about why
didn't have a twin we had this black kid
in my class with white parents and I
thought it was so [ __ ] dope oh my man
I wish I was adopted and I'd asked my
mom I'm like you know that story told me
when you picked me from the trash can
he's a real cuz you wanted it to be real
yeah
chuckles I'm adopted just you want that
title adopted kids are so your thing
like when you want braces yeah kids are
so [ __ ] dumb dude it's amazing as a
kid to like whoa they're lucky they have
glasses
palm trees like well he's on the board I
didn't really need glasses
and I need it I can't see [ __ ] I need
them and then I think that's Ross but
there's all right just wear them during
class I sort of worried I'm during
recess God and then my eyes got water so
worse and worse the fact that kids just
want to grow up like this but then they
don't realize like once you're grown up
forever that's Morristown I was jealous
of the welfare kids that got the paper
tickets for lunch and didn't breakfast
and [ __ ] did you see these kids - they
were [ __ ] jealous of kids who broke
their arm because they wanted the cat hi
hello me boobs I wanted to live in an
apartment not a house oh my god Paul
gonna hate this big house I'm gonna row
we have this kidding with hella bad
asthma and my asthma wasn't that bad and
in this fight before every Peter was
like [ __ ] man I wish my as most bad like
your [ __ ] to tell that [ __ ] like 25
inhaler so I could eat candy like in the
middle of class all the diabetes yeah
[ __ ] out of here dude I was in
elementary school I don't give up I
never said that [ __ ] I know your parents
robbed you of your childhood I'm sorry
no my parents will actually raise a
smart child everyone else in this room
can relate you were the minority
I don't really relate though because I
had the things that you guys wanted like
I had braces when I was like over there
saloon that you did that you wanted it
would be kind of where that you wanted I
just wanted normal human vision
yeah oh that's what I wanted you guys if
I the kids oh yeah what your grass
greener is us yeah like I wanted 2020
that's where glasses that make sense
people wanted to be like you
and then you wanna you wanted to be like
MIT anyways back to the story here so
this woman this takes place in China by
the way oh
she claims that she had two sons
actually gave birth to two of her kids
and they died and they both died in
their infancy and so I heard that
happens a lot when ladies their babies
die and they go oh that's my baby and
then they steal the baby
yeah so then she went to like seek
advice from elders and the elder said
that the only way she can have a child
of her own as if she would raise one
from another family so in 1982 what kind
of elders are these like like a mountain
men well these are it's from a village
super like folklore super the only way
you're gonna ever have a child is if you
steal one cuz nobody wanna marry your
[ __ ] ass she went to work as a nanny in
like the nearest major city of Chongqing
so she went undercover now yeah yeah cuz
she got a look that yeah she got a fake
ID and she got a job as a nanny for a
one-year-old boy and so she claims after
working for three days she took the baby
boy back to her village and started
raising him as a as her own son
so then duck who got gypped yes he lived
in the city then he has to go to a
village I know he didn't know but what
if he's raised with so much love and
care she's crazy I like that though I
think she's great you know why because
she probably cares so much because she
lives in a little village and then they
can live like happily together but if he
was in the city his parents always
working he's all neglect he has all this
money she was ready so it's like would
you rather be raised with love or lonely
with money lonely with money Yeah right
no but there's so many problems like
that though cuz I have a friend and like
her brother is like left alone at the
house all the time
he used to have a nanny that would take
care of him but then like the parents
fired her when I guess I'll just go to
titty milk no I don't know money reasons
or whatnot but fired her when he was
like in middle school but he was ballin
like he was no not ballin but like he
was like crying a lot yeah I get that
bothered okay i following you said a
show tug we couldn't get a copper
flossing from his money could like the
art like they do have some money to be
cool he was crying so much and like he
just completely shut himself away from
his parents and whatnot because like the
nanny was a person that was taking care
of yeah I can see that's what my mom
said though she goes like I was like hey
if I have a kid you gotta take care of
this case she goes no that's not smart
because during the infancy says when
they get really attached to you so if
you're if I'm doing it more than you are
and I'm always changing the diapers
they're gonna be more want to hear
something cool that's not true that
doesn't happen no it doesn't happen
because I know a personal friend of mine
who's grandma to care for most
and she's literally told me well after a
certain period of time yeah like if it's
from like I don't you answer to one year
and oh and over yeah then that's when
the attachment happens but
scientifically like anything when
they're in the knew it doesn't matter
that's still from one year older still
but they still the way like diapers that
one so there's still the same concept
right no it's just the the the stage
that their brain is in in terms of the
development after certain age so I think
it's I think it's probably twelve months
and on then that's when the attachment
happens I know but you're adding the age
thing I'm not adding an age thing I'm
saying like the kid is being taken care
of at an embassy stage all the way till
now so you're telling me off at 1 years
old I'm not saying at 1 I'm saying from
like you're going to like 8 or something
exactly so but your could tell you up
well I think what your mom is saying
though at least if it's in the beginning
like it could be your mom or whatever
and they're not gonna know a difference
just as long as it perceives love
no but you added that I didn't say that
I just said that my mom if my mom takes
care of the kid so you're adding stuff
that I didn't say you were saying so I'm
saying if my mom said like if I'm taking
care of the kid and changing the diapers
till whenever then they're gonna be
attached
I didn't say until 1 yeah I mean so
you're talking about yeah but that's
what I mean like oh so like for example
with my friend her grandma to camera
most of the time and literally had her
say I was like well what
I don't care I was like oh [ __ ] I have
that relationship with my grandma too
because a same situation we're like I
think well as an infant I probably had
both but then as soon as my mom had to
go back into work from the early stages
of maybe three and on to elementary
school it was I saw my grandma more than
I saw my mom I miss your crazy
yeah it's like weird my mom is my
grandma I think I got lucky that
everybody in my family gave me math
homework so I hate all them
you know I want them I really wish that
wasn't the case cuz I would only want to
take care of my kid when they could
speak now you got again you need to be
able to have that attachment cuz with
Isaac he was a baby and like I would be
working the whole day and I only see him
at night I'd like to put him to bed
I would feel that like that but he's I'm
like okay sees his mom know like the
babysitter was more visit her more cuz I
got going back to this lady here [ __ ]
pooping all over the place thank you
cute little [ __ ] oh yeah so then this
lady she got the little kid the
one-year-old boy in 1982 in 95 she gave
birth to a daughter and so at that time
she was considering returning the little
boy back to his family
well I would sorry a what age before she
considered returning him to his family
but then she was scared of being
prosecuted and going in could have left
them at the doorstep at a Chinese
firefighter she decided to just raise
her menses as her own for the rest of
his life and then not until recently she
was watching this TV documentary where
there was this old woman who had spent
the past 50 years of her life searching
for her kid oh my god hit her she was
like oh my god I need to tell my son the
truth and I need to tell the police and
maybe hopefully they could find lated
guilt-trip I know
26 I have no guilt at that point I'm I
bet you at this maybe because at this
point she's a [ __ ] mean ass and she's
like alright finally I'm gonna tell
argument you know it turns out that the
son doesn't believe my mom and he's like
I don't
to find my biological parents anyways
you're my mom like oh he would have
never ever imagined that that isn't his
mother because of the way that she
raised him as like her own damn what a
positive person Chinese I would let this
I think if I lost Tiger after like ten
years I a little flat for no more from
ten years is a long it's a long time ten
years listening called a stop that mom
kept going at 26
just over oh well I oh I don't know no
fifty years the one in the documentary
with yet they were searching for 50
years see that's a long ass [ __ ] time
yeah I would never stop but also it's
one child over there right no that's my
cha I've made this child my mother more
I think for me after the first month I'm
like the key is we just gotta be like
baby boomer style and have a lot of kids
cuz if a couple of them die it's okay
that's right that's how Asian people do
it now that she came out with this story
she's trying to find the his actual
biological parents but it's weird
because that doesn't care there have
been no police records of any missing
boy that person did history what like
just like Ovaltine kids pig wing died I
don't know is that his name was yeah and
what if like let's say you find them
right like let's say so you have
attachment of typos I'm talking about
when there is an attachment a tiger he's
gone for ten years and then let's say
you find you find I don't know how
there's never an attachment there's the
biological attachment and then there's
always guys pretty dope attachment I'm
talking bout this guy's pretty dope
attachment before that sets in let's say
Tigers gone right then for 10 years
later you're like I was nowhere he
called I don't know and then finally
they found them right and I'll take it
there you are and he goes to you I think
girls have the that's pretty dope
attachment is just from the start oh
damn alright let's put this been 29
years
[Music]
you found Tigers just like this fool and
his even call you uh no I love it
no I would do what's or you I'd be like
[ __ ] like you're still my kid like I
made you no wonder I'm so [ __ ] tall
[Music]